Quantum computing is entered the era of utility
meaning that we can begin to use quantum computers to solve
real world problems including some that are very difficult
for classical computers
a common theme in the current era
is that a problem is solved
for the first time on a quantum computer
and then subsequently people find a way to do it on a classical
computer this cycle of classical
and quantum computing pushing each other to their
limits will likely continue
for a few years there are classes of problems where quantum
computing can have approvable advantage
over classical computing
given progress in areas such
as reduction of errors and the number of cubits available
there are also entire application areas
where quantum computing
might be useful in the relatively near term
one of these areas is quanta machine learning or qml
quanta machine learning refers to
the application of quantity computing to any type of machine
learning process there are of course
many types of machine learning
two types of particular interest or
supervised learning in which you
train in algorithm using a labeled dataset
and unsupervised learning in which
the algorithm works from unlabeled samples
and attempts to learn about the distribution
or the function that generates it
an unsupervised algorithm might
for example learn how to generate new samples
from the same distribution or how to
cluster the samples into groups with similar characteristics
both supervised and unsupervised learning often involved
the embedding of data in higher dimensional spaces
and manipulation of data in higher dimensional spaces
should make us think of quantum computing
let me explain imagine trying to solve the problem of whether
to classify a data point from the plane
as a circle or a cross given the labeled training data here
sometimes data can be clearly separated by a line
or plane in low dimensions
as shown here and classifying these data points according
to those above the line
and below the line should be
no problem but look at this distribution
clearly there's no visible line that separates the data points
however for this data we could imagine some
mapping from two dimensions to three dimensions
such that after applying the mapping our data looks
like this and there's clearly a plane which separates the two
classes in which we can use
for classification if this treatment seems a bit simplistic
you're right we can't just put the data points we want
further up with no justification
there has to be a mapping
from the two d distribution that effectively separates
our data points so we can
use the mapping to classify new data points
this will be discussed more in the lesson giving a machine
learning recap but suffice it to say
that the problem can be viewed
as trying many different mappings into this higher dimensional
space to see which mappings yield the best
separation of data points of different classes
this manipulation of data in higher dimensions
is one area where quantum computing
may have a big impact to understand why
let's return to the differences between classical
and quantum computing just
as classical computers use bits of information
quantum computers use cubits
but for a given number of bits say four
a classical computer can take on any of the
two to the four or sixteen possible states
a quantum computer can also access sixteen possible states
but it can exist in a super position of all
sixteen states simultaneously
and operations can be performed on this entire superposition
for four cubits this may not seem
like such a big deal but imagine what could be done with
a quantum computer in two to the twenty or
two to the one hundred and twenty seven
states simultaneously there are many other differences
between classical and quantity computing that will
all play a role in this subject
quantum states have complex probability amplitudes
manipulations of quantum systems are carried out with
unitary operators and quantum computers are subject to different
kinds of noise than classical computers
these differences will come up
throughout your quantity machine learning work in areas
like data encoding feature mapping in error mitigation
in some cases these differences between classical
and quantum computers allow us to design entirely
new algorithms now that was a very brief overview
to the union of two immensely complicated fields
but hopefully two things are clear
machine learning often solves problems
by manipulating data in very high dimensions
and second quantum computers are well suited
to manipulating data in high dimensions
and do so differently than classical systems
this should give you a sense
for why machine learning is a promising field
for the application of useful quantum computing